[Music]  [Music]  thank you  people  let's make the dream happen  we need a [ __ ] hit  action  [Music]  these people are wondering whether you  still got that fire I'm worried she's  having another psychotic break it's a  lot it's a lot so give them what they  love look at the camera and [ __ ]  everyone in America [ __ ] them and [ __ ]  em good  Los Angeles is where all the monsters of  the world come together trust no one  I feel like everyone's losing their  minds where did he come from  [Music]  let people enjoy sex drugs and hot girls  okay stop trying to [ __ ] block America  [Music]  fire up the mic let's go  [Music]  full control  [Music]  [ __ ] what  thank you  so where should we start  [Applause]